you and um I'm delighted to introduce
our next speaker Elizabeth purdom she is
associate professor in the department of
Statistics here at Berkeley and also the
faculty director of the center for
computational biology and she'll be
talking to us about
multimodal sequence single cell
sequencing data for integrative analysis
so thanks very much Elizabeth
great thank you I'm gonna
dispense with my mask for the top yeah
so
um
I'm going to take the organizers uh for
organizing the conference and inviting
me to talk and as you can see by the
large number of talks we've had about
single cell uh sequencing data is
clearly creating a large number of New
Opportunities
um in exploring problems biology and
biology evaluation of cell type
diversity developmental changes cancer
Evolution being able to go from
sequencing a mass of cells to sequencing
an individual cell is
clearly very transformative for certain
questions
um I was going to take a moment to think
about this a little bit more from the
point of view of a methodologist when I
got my PhD I was working on microarrays
which were kind of Big Data at the time
measured huge number of features for the
time and um but at the same time the
number of samples was modest and of
course as since that time period so now
we have these vast data sets in other
other areas where they just sort of
scoop up data on our as we go about our
social interactions and on the internet
and so forth but for me at least most of
my uh projects that I'm involved with
the the size of the data set is stayed
sort of
um stubbornly modest in terms of the
number of uh sample sizes so it's sort
of a different
um way of thinking or analyzing the data
then
then some of modern advancements and
thinking about you know how to deal with
Google social networks and so forth so
one thing that's interesting to me is
that in working like single cell data at
least for me personally is a slight
paradigm shift in the sense that now we
easily have hundreds of thousands of
cells you saw from previous talks you
can easily have a million cells
um and
um
so for me this has been kind of exciting
in terms of being able to think
differently about my problems from when
I had only 100 uh samples so in thinking
about what to talk about today I decided
to talk about a project of that I worked
on with a student that sort of
exemplifies for me sort of uh an example
where I kind of shifted paradigms and
ways I would have thought about the
problem
um
so that's just sort of my big picture uh
overview of my motivation for for
talking about this
um what I'm going to talk about
specifically
um I want to give a little bit of a
background too I think a number of the
talks today have been focused largely on
measuring mRNA the transcriptome
but there are single cell Technologies
for if not all many of the bulk
technologies that existed before for
sequencing so for example there's many
areas in epigenetics where we can do
single cell sequencing and expand Beyond
bulk as well so examples are things like
open chromatin methylation uh proteins
binding to DNA and so forth and I'll
talk specifically just to give a little
bit of background about open chromatin
to make sure we're all familiar because
this is one that's actually become
really uh fairly frequent in single cell
sequently on atax seek
and the idea here is of course our DNA
is quite large is generally to be able
to fit compactly in the cell is tightly
packed and closed but in order to be
able to transcribe genes uh that packing
needs to open up so that the gene can be
accessed by the
transcriptional machinery
and so open chromatin basically is going
to be trying to evaluate where is the
chromatin open versus tightly packed and
so you get reads and I won't go through
the technical procedures but you get
reads more um from the DNA that is
accessible
and so you might have something that
looks uh like this where in the tightly
packed regions you don't have a lot of
reads and in the open uh and the open
regions you have these Peaks
so that's just one example and it's an
epigenetic trait it's not something
built into the DNA but something we want
to measure and it clearly has large
interactions with transcriptome because
of course regions that are going to be
transcribed will have areas open but
other more distal regions can also be
open for enhancers and things like this
that are necessary for transcription
um and so many of these are often done
not I mean they're often not completely
in isolation but also in conjunction
with doing transcriptome sequencing from
the same biological uh system
so an area of great deal of interest is
how to combine these different
modalities and there's kind of different
settings for which this can happen one
setting is to do the two different
Technologies the MRNA sequencing and the
ATAC sequencing for example on two
different experiments from the same
basic system in other words on different
cells you burst open the cell and so
forth so it's easier to do it on
separate cells and there's various
techniques for trying to analyze and
combine data when they're um
so to try to find commonalities this is
usually requires you even though these
modalities are not necessarily measured
on genes we have these Peaks which may
or may not be over Gene regions uh these
modalities get summarized into something
that has to do with genes and they're
related up by looking at the gene
measurements from the RNA and the gene
measurements from the Peaks for example
and putting those together for shared
patterns helps you link up these two
data sets
so that's kind of uh option one in terms
of the type of experiment one might have
but as was very briefly mentioned in the
previous talk there are also
technologies that sequence the same cell
um in multiple ways
um so what do I mean by that I'll take
the example the running example here of
ATAC seek with mRNA and there's several
technologies that actually from the same
cells try to measure both of these
quantities so we'll have cells and on
each cell we can have measurements of
the gene expression but we can also have
those Peaks the counts of the Peaks
and so one question is how to jointly
analyze these two data sets
um as this sort of toy cartoon might
sort of illustrate the Peaks are
generally can be of a sort of different
nature than the genes more sparse and so
forth and trying to put them together in
a way that's not just combining them
into one being Matrix to try to get a
unified representation
another goal we were particularly
interested in is thinking more
holistically about the entire experiment
one might run a joint on a certain
number of cells get both modalities but
it's also much easier and a more tried
and true system to run them separately
so we might on the same system also have
cells that are only have the gene
expression Theta and cells that have
only for example the ATAC the open
chromatin measurements and so we're
interested about how to uh integrate
this data
um this kind of data when it's collected
on multiple platforms and of course you
could have multiple versions of each of
these
um going forward
[Music]
um and sort of as a side goal we also
are interested in not having to
summarize the Peaks into genes but
actually use the full Peaks right
because especially since you can have
distal elements that are important uh
for expression we uh we would like to be
able to not have to throw out that
information so not a primary goal but it
was something we were interested in
so what do I mean by a unified
representation so I'll kind of walk you
through the ideas uh that went into the
particular strategy we did but I would
like to say this is a very active area
and these kind of ideas are uh in a lot
of different
um methods both that were coming out at
the same time as ours and in other
related areas so
um the basic strategy what we mean by a
unified representation is that we think
that there's that there's some
underlying latent uh variables
that uh are
are
[Music]
a property of the cell we can think of
them if we like idealistically in
embedding the true biological processes
and that these um to be able to get to
mRNA and then what we of course measure
is a process that these latent variables
go through to create the count data that
we see from the RNA and similarly to for
open chromatin that creates another
process that gives us the data and so
for these these same yellow ones where
we get to observe both the end products
of both but the idea is that they come
from one shared latent variable and if
we did on these cells get both it would
be the same in other words there's these
latent variables that we want to use
and what we'd like to do then is
estimate from the data uh these Z's so
we start with this set of data and we
want to get some
some estimate of these latent variables
for all the cells regardless of which
platforms or combination of platforms we
have measured them with
once we have those then those can be
used for Downstream tasks for things
like visualization and also of course
clustering to try to identify subtypes
um
okay so I'll start first with the
um where we started and then kind of
build up from there
um
so the first idea was built on some
ideas
uh that had become current in single
cell and again this takes advantage of
the large number of
um cells so this is kind of going back
to my original point I think
embarrassingly that's actually my phone
so unfortunately even though it's
silenced it decided to go off anyways
okay sorry about that
um
so using uh ideas of variational Auto
encoders for example scvi which is
um I was created by near yoso's group
and others here at Berkeley using
variational autoencoders to try to take
for example just with one data set to
try to estimate these latent variables
and they rely on using
um neural networks to approximate the
posterior distribution of these latent
variables and there's some generative
model which is the portion over here of
how you go from the latent variables to
the counts and and that we
um you can encode for various different
models such as have been talked about
with previous uh
speakers such as zero inflated negative
binomial
there's also multimodal variational
autoencoders vaes which uh have the idea
of taking different modalities such as
we have before and actually developing
different neural nets for each one to
encode how you would get the prior
distribution and and and similarly have
a generative model like I described
before
so that was our first idea was to
basically do a straightforward kind of
uh implementation of these strategies
and one problem we found at least in the
data that we were looking at was in fact
the open chromatin data was really
sensitive to how the generative model we
chose to use in a way that the RNA
sequencing data was not and so in
particular this is just one example
that's easy to to draw but this was true
with other types of approaches this is
just sort of a standard analysis in
Surat using their standard tools for for
chromatin ataxique of the kind of and a
visualization of of their reduced
dimensionality while another strategy
that used a very different
um approach this topic got something
that was much more well defined in terms
of its subtypes
and so we uh so that uh these kind of
problems made it very difficult uh made
this strategy actually not work well for
us and so we uh we adapted further to
try to make advantage of what systoptic
uses which is latent richly allocation
model
so if you're not familiar with that I'll
just briefly describe it it's created in
the context of documents um where the
accounts You observe the number of
frequency of words in a document and you
assume and documents are expected to
have various different topics that
they're encoded in so you assume that
the counts You observe are actually a
mixture in other words an additive sum
of the the counts the words being used
for different topics okay so there's
some parameter this Theta which gives
you the proportion for any particular
cell or document of each of the topics
that are
um done and for the biology setting you
can think of this as different
biological processes you know some RNA
is going for one process some is going
for another process you add it up is
what you see and so Theta that's
idealistic obviously but
um Theta C would be the proportion of
those processes that this particular
cell needed
um and then you have a parameter that
converts that lets you know given each
topic how much do you get of each gene
and so by putting those two together
this is independent of cell this is just
shared across say all of mRNA and this
is per cell by putting those together
you can actually get your observed
counts which is going to be uh say a
multinomial across this combination
so
um this is the cystopic strategy in
order to make it work in our multimodial
type of context we use uh sort of a vae
version of LEDs LDA where we take a
transformation of our uh we assume that
our parameter that's of Interest that's
the proportions that's kind of our
latent variable we assume that it's
actually a soft Max transformation of
those Z's we're actually interested in
so we're still back to our Z Model and
when we have those Z's we can transform
them to get them into proportions
um and this is using a standard
um standard softmax transformation
and then instead of using a Jerusalem
prior we're going to be
um assuming that the we're going to be
approximating the distribution instead
of thinking about the prior of the
thetas we're going to be trying to model
the prior disease and then our vae will
then be modeling or approximating
because it's variational autoencoder
approximation the prior distribution of
disease with a multivariate normal
so putting those pieces together is the
model that we developed for
the multimodality where this is the same
picture as before only now instead of
using uh
the the previous generative model we're
going to put in the parameters for the
uh we're going to be instead modeling
the the LDA there
so just to give you a sense of what this
looks like in practice how do you
actually use this in the end what we get
out are estimate Z for our different
modalities
and so for example this is a data set on
the mouse cortex where there were
separate there were
um
single cell mRNA and ATEC seek and then
also snare seek on
um
on another from another group but also
from the same
um the same system and so we look at
integrating these together here is just
a representation uh umap representation
of those Z Matrix the Z latent variables
they're in a much higher dimensional
space but this is just a two-dimensional
representation
and so on the left here we can see them
color-coded by the different data sets
they come from and here we can see them
color coded by the clustering
um the known not known but the cell
types that are that were identified uh
from the paper and in the case here we
um identified them de novo from our
representation and so we can see that
that they uh you know well categorized
and this is true in other data sets
we also so we looked at various
different things one thing that's sort
of nice about working with these paired
data is we actually know of course that
they come together but we can pretend we
don't know and that gives us sort of
fake data it's real data but we don't we
actually know which ones should go
together we can pretend we don't and we
can analyze sort of how well we do at
being able to put these data sets
together and so
um and then this is and why do we do
this I mean there's a lot of different
reasons one is these are very like
large-scale groups that are pretty hard
to not get definitely so we wanted to
look at a like more local level how well
they were doing and
um
so we're looking sort of uh if we use
these techniques in others if we pretend
going back to oh it's way back here okay
if we pretend that
um
are red and blue data sets another
isolated this that's their paired data
will pretend they're not and we'll put
them into our model and see how closely
we're able to align them together
and so this is just basically how well
we're able to align them with a higher
proportion meaning that you get more of
the ones that should be together close
together and this is our strategy here
we've compared it to some other
strategies as I said this is a busy and
um
growing area and so these are two
different data sets where we've done
similar things and we we can see it the
very more detailed level in terms of
like which cells are actually close to
each other in our latent space are we
doing a good job of actually pairing
them together and saying which cells
should be similar to each other that
we're doing better than these other
strategies
and going back to my side note if I add
some more lines in here we also tried
looking at different ways to actually
pre-process the data and indeed this
line here is that I have point with an
arrow is if we instead summarize them
based on genes with our model with
Cobalt and we ignore some of that Peak
and satisfyingly we do get higher we do
do better when we actually use the full
set of information and not just the gene
um strategies
so
um so that's kind of an overview of uh
of how our method works but also just
sort of these ideas like how people are
approaching these multi uh modality data
sets
um
and so I guess maybe just to close I'm
going to go back to my original slide
saying oh I have all of this data and
how nice this is I and maybe comments on
that a little bit more in the sense of
most many large uh census or Atlas
projects the goal is to really discover
sort of the diversity of cell types and
to get as many cells as one can and in
that setting for example
it's part of a mouse a brain Atlas
project that I was tangentially sort of
related to you know you to get enough
cells you might have multiple mice that
you use as donors for the cells that
provide Gene matrices and they're going
to be hopefully homogeneous genetically
identical very similar and what's
usually done is of course we're going to
group them all together we might try to
look for batch effects we might try to
remove them you know we'll try to be
sophisticated about it but in the end we
they're combined together in basically
one very large Matrix which is more or
less what I've done here
however when we move Beyond and we try
to think more about human health setting
and this is maybe a little bit more like
the um setting that was in the previous
talk it's a kind of different setting in
this setting we would have multiple
patients
and each one would provide single cell
RNA sequencing data and we no longer
want to have homogeneous or we no longer
will have homogeneous groups despite my
poor little cartoons and they should be
quite different and have population
variability and so we want to be able to
capture that variability not remove it
and be able to determine whether that
variability is due for example between
different phenotypes of Interest disease
versus control and what of that is
population variability and so forth and
so in some sense that brings us back
full circle to my modest data set sizes
again
um in the sense that the number of data
sets these data sets are growing
um as uh more and more of these types of
experiments are run but we're still
talking about you know modest cohorts 40
100 patients and so forth
and so one area that we're quite
interested in my group is actually this
question of what is the right way to
combine these data sets together which
is fundamentally a question that's going
to vary for all the different kinds of
single cell type of questions we might
want to ask of the data
so there's my asterisk to my excitement
previously about the data set sizes
um and I will finish by saying this is
the work I presented today is uh the
work of my student uh who is it uh
boying gong but I want to recognize that
I have very nice collaborations in
General on lots of different single cell
sequencing experiments a number of
people in this room and so uh they've
also been helpful and this is the paper
uh of this particular method that came
out in genome biology last year
okay I think I'll stop there
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um so thank you very much
um so you are looking at the latent
structure of the different uh on mixed
modalities and single cells and try to
somehow find which is a common latent
structure and somehow I can imagine that
there is a strong relationship between
chromatin accessibility a gene
expression so that's this latent
structure exists but I can also imagine
that very interesting question is which
are cell types of subsets of our cells
in which this is not happening so there
is something that is not uh I mean there
is there's a structure that is not
shared right because that's I don't know
indicates some kind of a regulatory
problem maybe so is your methodology is
also able to identify this
kind of different type of latent spaces
across modalities
yes so the
um
yes and maybe no as you as your question
continued onward
um I I had to rethink it but finally
this latent this model here
um has this B which goes basically from
your latent variable into what you get
for each gene and I didn't explicitly
say that when we moved to a
multi-modality model this B is going to
be different for every modality
um so you can have consistent
um
strategies for how
you know what you're how your latent
variables translate into the modality
data and that's modality specific right
so you could have
You know despite using process one
it could be that process one doesn't
turn anything on in the chromatin and it
does in the RNA for example now you
started as the question moved on to talk
about cell type specificity
um and I think the cell type specificity
would instead have to be encapsulated in
these proportions
right and those are per cell
so they so while we're not modeling cell
type per se
you could think that there's a hierarchy
of
um these latent variables that amongst
different cell types they will have
different underlying latent variables
and in some sense that goes I guess back
to the prior which you're trying to
estimate empirically
okay
so
um so this is maybe a little related to
Anna's question and I think I'm
constructing my answer in my head but
I'll ask the question if you want to add
something else so is there any um
intermediate influence objects
um in your model that helps you learn uh
in interactions between Gene and Peaks
so that you can learn regulatory
programs yes so this is something that
we've explored but not uh really gotten
to prime time so I um which is this
question this sort of comes into this B
Matrix where you get a different one for
each modality and that's kind of work in
progress as to how successful that is
honestly so I can't say more than that
but that would that's our strategy and
something we're investigating right now
is how you could use those to try to
have
um to make explicit those relationships
um
yeah
[Music]
yeah
I mean following up on the same sort of
theme and obviously other methods make
strong assumptions right of sharing
features and you know promoter
accessibility gene expression and and
you make another assumption understand
those relationships in some way I was
wondering whether they're useful in the
mediates I mean one of them is you know
local proximity even if you don't make
promoter accessibility things that are
near a gene might be more related to
that or
um or other information whether they're
wasters or encode this prior knowledge
column quote in in your model because I
think you're it's unconstrained in a way
right you could have shared latent
variable of things that are even on
different chromosomes and there's
wondering whether that's something
useful to explore or possible to encode
in this framework that's a that's a good
point
um I did come in with the bias of
struggling with trying to work with atax
so you can Define it in terms of genes
um in this working with a collaborator
and like what is the distance how far
does that have to be away so on and so
forth and so I did come in with the bias
of like oh I don't want to do that right
I really want to just deal with the
Peaks and you know figure out what they
tell but I agree that in some ways the
model
um is is over uh
overly open in that respect
so again I think this would come back to
putting constraints into these uh B
coefficients and
um but it's true I haven't I haven't
thought I thought about more like
Sunday's question like how do you
interpret them when you get them out and
so I hadn't really thought about that
from a like a regularization point of
view but it's a good idea
foreign